[موسيقى]
اسمي شيخه شيبه لما كان عمري 18 شهر طلع
فيني سرطان في العظم والمستشفى اضطرت انه
يبتلون اليد وبديت مشواري من من 18 شهر
لليوم ولا اليوم عمري 40 سنه انا من
صعوبات اللي واجهتها من صغري التنمر
التنمر والله لين اليوم موجود فقلت نمر من
الصغر كان اصعب لانه الوقت اللي قبل كان
ما كان في توعيه نفس الحين كان وايد صعب
علي اني اتقبل نفسي اتقبل شكلي اتقبل
حياتي بالطريقه اللي انا كنت فيها كنت
وايد اخجل من اللي انا فيه فانا قبل ما
كنت اروح المدرسه الا باليد الصناعيه
بعدين شوي شوي بديت اتقبل شوي شوي بدي
اتقبل لما الناس بالمدرسه بتتنمر علي لما
تسالني شنو فيك وبعدها مع الوقت بديت
اتقبل كل شيء خطوه بخطوه وبدها تعلم انا
شلون اعيش حياتي بالطريقه اللي انا
عايشتها اليوم
وشلون احب نفسي وبالطريقه اللي انا حابه
نفسي فيها اليوم
انا كنت شوي متروسه وكنت حابه انزل وزني
فكنت اروح الجيم ولما رحت الجيم في بعض
المجربين ما كانوا يتقبلوني انا كشيخه في
الجيم وتدرب كان يقول لي انت ما تقدرين
تسوين في اشياء معليش شيخه انت اضعف فهدني
وايد زعلت بديت ادخل الرياضات انا كل يوم
عن يوم اذا ممكن
حبي للرياضه يزيد لانه شفت التغيير في
نفسي وشفت القوه في عقلي وفي جسدي
بوصل صوره واوصل معلومه ترى لما احنا رب
العالمين ياخذ منه شيء بس احنا معوضينه
باشياء الثانيه غير يعني انا مو ما عندي
بالعكس انا الله اعطاني كل شيء
اقدر اقول لو يرجع فيني زمن واكون اختار
ان انا يكون عندي يدين ولا يد بختار شكلي
الحين اللي انا فيه بالقوه اللي انا فيها
بالعزيمه اللي انا فيها لانه لو كنت ما
كنت بصير نفس مانع الحين
انا بالنسبه ليك يا شيخه كل بنت رياضيه هي
مصدر الهام لانه كلنا لما ندخل في مجال
الرياضه عندنا صعوبات احنا لازم نجتازها
واحنا نحاول نوصل رساله للعالم انه ترى ما
في شيء مستحيل وكل شيء الانسان يحط عقله
فيه يقدر يسويه
[موسيقى]